[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce matin ça a été une journée importante
pour la municipalité aussi pour les
nouveaux habitants du quartier puisque
nous avons inauguré le parc du moulon
qui est en fait le principal espace
végétal de ce quartier par la suite nous
avons pu inaugurer en deux mois passés
devant la mairie annexe de moulon et qui
permettra aux habitants du quartier mais
aussi à l'ensemble des gifs wade faire
des démarches administratives et cartes
d'identité les passeports toute une
série de l'égalisation donc l'ouverture
est prévue pour février 2020 ensuite on
s'est rapproché de la future crèche du
futur pôle médical qui devrait
accueillir prochainement trois médecins
généralistes la crèche quant à elle
devant accueillir 55 perso à l'horizon 2
septembre 2020 enfin monsieur le maire a
invité les participants à inaugurer le
groupe scolaire de moulon dans lequel
nous sommes qui comprend également un
son de loisirs et un gymnase qui est
ouvert à la fois pro public scolaire
mais aussi pour les associations
chinoises
on a des habitants comme dirait du
sommaire des vrais habitants ce qui
n'est pas faire bien entendu mon enfance
aux étudiants mais les étudiants par
définition sont de passage donc nous
sommes ravis d'avoir des habitants à
d'honneur et puis qu'ils y habitent en
10 des enfants et évidemment ça permet à
ce groupe scolaire de vivre depuis
maintenant un mois avec une classe
ouverte avec 28 enfants
[Musique]
il y à 4200 mètres carrés de surfaces
commerciales qui est prévue sur sur la
centralité du quartier donc avec toute
une diversité de commerces coiffure il y
aura des restaurants c'était chose très
importante aussi pour la vie du quartier
il est prévu une moyenne surface
alimentaire d'environ 8 mètres carrés
qui permettra d'offrir tous les services
attendus par la population en termes
alimentaire il y aura une pharmacie il y
aura une agence bancaire avec un
distributeur de billets bref tout un
panel de commerce que nous pouvons
retrouver d'ailleurs d'angie vallée où
surgissent chevret
donc la première phase du programme
horizon et est achevée la seconde phase
est en cours est en cours de réalisation
et devraient être achevés d'ici deux ans
plus tard avec notamment un programme de
logements relativement important et d'où
des nouveaux habitants à terme
[Musique]